I to killing of India can become a
superpower in the command years to come
or the decades to come but what India
needs to strengthen from inside is its
infrastructure its energy security
dependence on various forms of energy
needs to be increased primarily with
focus on renewables like solar wind and
various other forms of energy education
is another thing that needs to be
strengthened to create a workforce for
the world which adds quality and value
for all the services around the world
Manufacturing is another area that India
needs to focus on and it's already doing
getting the highways in place to move
the Indian economic goods in and out of
the country within the country making
the hinterlands reaching out to the
hinterland the power telecom and various
other progressive materials is what
makes India a superpower in of the
future and I think we are geared up for
that and we should be going for it